mon réveil n'a pas sonné je suis d'abord
car tu manges pas le matin sur les
écrans dira jamais de kout malo moi
aussi je suis en retard on est tous
sortent un moment faut que tu apprennes
à 13 pour stabiliser mon grand 34 35
38e alors c'est tout
[ __ ] c'est moi et elles sont sept à
dix sous la porte tu fais quoi là je
priais six mois
faut que ça change tout faire pour qu'on
soit des mecs en place
comme ce sera fun berthelot le mec qui
chope une correspondante est seul avec
des nichons énorme tu vois changement de
vie relooking extrême ascenseur social
réputation mythique
il faut qu'on va correspondre qu'à me de
grosses sommes ni shônen quoi et moi
j'ai un certain
merci et voici sacha brüggen
je souhaite être les meilleurs amis du
monde correspondant qu'est ce que c'est
c'est qu'il a gothic qui voit la vierge
à foison de sacha règle à redevenir
camarades avec son correspondant c'est
très bien toi tu dors par terre règle b
partager avec votre correspondant vos
hobbies vos loisirs
tout est une blogueuse la vengeance est
un plat qui se mange froid
quand tu parle français toi et cette
fois qu'on passe sur les américains pour
sauver ton petit q3 dessous du pair
l'effet correspondant commence à se
faire sentir
la vengeance ça se voit tout aussi pas
deviner comment évoquer petit tu veux
devenir populaire bah oui je veux
devenir populaire je veux devenir
programme ta gueule mais sacha mais
qu'est ce qui vous a fait rien
quatre heures de colle samedi matin doit
bien et moi chérie on a un gros problème
avec la petite poche
t'as pas pu faire l'espagnol toi
hoste